washington quiere volver a liderar los
esfuerzos globales contra el cambio
climático y lo quiere hacer con una mano
tendida a francia ya la unión europea
ese fue el mensaje del enviado especial
para el clima de eeuu john kerry tras su
visita a parís
y cuando decimos que américa ha
regresado no lo decimos con arrogancia o
sentido de superioridad hemos regresado
para ser socios para luchar y hacer el
trabajo
elpresidente macrón indicó que quiere
trabajar con el presidente bailen de
manera cercana
kerry regresó precisamente a francia
para marcar el regreso de eeuu al
acuerdo de parís un acuerdo que él mismo
forjó como secretario de estado en la
administración obama y que donald trump
abandonó pocos años después un viraje
que el país galo celebra
visite juniors pastas news y toxic y
eeuu y europa de nuevo comparten un
objetivo dos continentes desarrollados y
poderosos que comparten la voluntad de
luchar contra el cambio climático y
bajar las emisiones para ganar esta
batalla
aquí el gobierno de joe biden aseguró
que habrán nuevos compromisos climáticos
de eeuu durante el mes de abril antes de
la próxima cumbre del clima de las
naciones unidas en glasgow reino unido
en noviembre donde muchos esperan volver
a ponerse manos a la obra bajo un nuevo
liderazgo de washington